كيف ينتشر هذا بشكل جيد
يبدو أنه ينتشر مع
اتصال بشري مغلق ، أعني في البداية أنه كان هناك
قلق داخل تلك الأسواق في ووهان
من أسواق الحيوانات تلك من أنها
كانت تقفز من الحيوانات إلى البشر ،
وهو ما حدث بصراحة وأنت وأنا
أندرسون  سافرت ، تعلم أنك قد تتذكر
أننا في إفريقيا ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي تصل بها الكثير من
الفيروسات إلى البشر ،
وهناك شيء يسمى
فيروسات ZOA الملحوظة بالضبط وهذه
هناك هذه الثرثرة المستمرة التي
تحدث ، حيث يقوم الفيروس بتبديل
الحيوانات ذهابًا وإيابًا مع البشر و  أيضًا البشر
إلى الحيوانات ومعظمهم لا يسبب
أي نوع من الأمراض ولن
تعرف ذلك حقًا ولكن بين
الحين والآخر يقوم الفيروس بقفزة يقوم العامل
الممرض بالقفز ويسبب مرضًا
رأيناه مع الآخرين  فيروسات من نفس
عائلة الفيروس التاجي ، كان السارس أحد تلك
الأمثلة ،
مايرز يرمز لمتلازمة الشرق الأوسط
التنفسية واحدة أخرى من
تلك الأمثلة ، لكن
هذا هو الحال عادةً.  إن الانتقال من
حيوان إلى إنسان الآن في الصين
يبدو أنه أكثر طرق
انتقال المرض شيوعًا هو من إنسان إلى
إنسان وعادة ما يكون على اتصال وثيق ، لذلك
يختلف على سبيل المثال من ثلاثة إلى ستة أقدام عن
شيء مثل الحصبة إذا
كنت في هذا  الغرفة وقد أصبت بالحصبة حتى
بعد ساعتين إذا جاء شخص ما
إلى هذه الغرفة التي لم يتم تطعيمها
، فيمكن أن يصاب بالحصبة هنا ، إنه
قريب جدًا من الاتصال الوثيق بمسافة ثلاثة إلى ستة
أمتار كما يقولون ومن ثم قد
يعيش الفيروس على الأسطح التي يمكنك  المس
لبضع ساعات بعد ذلك يموت الفيروس
إذا لمست هذا الفيروس ثم لمست
أنفك فمك ، فهذه طريقة أخرى
يمكن أن يصاب بها
الأشخاص إذا كان الأشخاص المصابون بالفيروس
بدون أعراض ، ما مدى فعالية
حظر السفر لأنه حتى لو لم تفعل ذلك  إذا كنت مصابًا
بالحمى ،
فقد تكون مصابًا بالفيروس ، نعم لا ،
هذه نقطة جيدة حقًا
وأعني أن الشخص يقول بشكل أساسي ،
انظر أنه من الممكن أن يأتي شخص مصاب
سوف يجتاز جميع الفحوصات تمامًا.
لأنهم بدون أعراض يمكنهم
السفر حول العالم عدة مرات في
غضون أيام قليلة ثم تظهر عليهم الأعراض بشكل
صحيح تمامًا وهذا ما
تعرفه بغض النظر عن عدد
الفاشيات التي غطيتها والتي تظهر
دائمًا هي فترة الحضانة هذه
أود أن أقول إنه لهذا السبب
من الصعب جدًا تخيل أن
حظر السفر من الصين
سيكون بالضرورة فعالًا
لأن فترة الحضانة هذه أعتقد أنه من
المنطقي قصر سفرك على
منطقة مصابة معروفة مثل  أ أنت تعرف
مقاطعة هوبي في ووهان في الصين ولكن
بخلاف ذلك لنقول نوعًا ما أن نطاقات
السفر الأكبر والأكثر شمولاً هذه
فقط من علم
فيزيولوجي وبالنظر إلى وباء
المرض فإنه لا يصنع الكثير من  بمعنى
[موسيقى]
يا
فريزر ، حسنًا
أوه
مرحباً ، أنا جاستن روبرسون ، أنا مصور صحفي لشبكة سي إن إن
مقيم في بكين ، لقد
ركبت للتو رحلة من فرانكفورت إلى
بكين ومن المدهش أنني لم
أر شيئًا مثل ذلك
يرتدي كل شخص على متن هذه الرحلة
نوعًا من أنواع الأقنعة لحماية
أنفسهم من هذا الفيروس.
وذلك لأسباب تتعلق بالنظافة
[موسيقى]